Es ist der 19. Januar im Jahr 2038, kurz vor 5. Weil du sehr früh aufstehen musst, ausnahmsweise hast du dir drei Wecker gestellt, weil du weißt, wie schwer du aus dem Bett kommst, wenn es so früh ist. Aber seltsamerweise hat nur der dritte Wecker geklingelt, ein altes mechanisches Geschenk deiner Urgroßeltern. Verwirrt wachst du auf, greifst nach deinem Smartphone und siehst, es ist Viertel vor eins. Warum hat der Wecker geklingelt? Das Smartphone sagt auch, es ist 1970. Und außerdem ist es sehr dunkel, weil dein Licht nicht funktioniert. Und es ist sehr kalt in deiner Wohnung. Und als du aus dem Fenster schaust, stürzen Flugzeuge vom Himmel. Und die einzige Lichtquelle, die die Stadt erleuchtet, ist eine riesige Explosion am Stadtrand. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 257. Hallo und guten Abend.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Das ist Andreas Bogk. Hallo. Hallo. Er ist schon häufiger mal zu Gast gewesen. Und wir müssen heute über ein ernsthaftes Problem reden, das wir schon mal gehabt haben und vielleicht bald wieder haben werden. Nämlich ein Zeitproblem.
Also viele Leute kennen das, man hat immer zu wenig Zeit, aber manchmal, ganz manchmal läuft die Zeit auch über. Und das ist heute das Thema.
Manchmal, manchmal läuft die Zeit über, genau. Und zwar gibt es die Befürchtung, dass am 19. Januar 2038, um 4.14.07, Dein Einsatz Andreas?
Plus, minus ein paar Sekunden, darüber sprechen wir später noch.
Genau, dass dann irgendwas kaputt geht. Was könnte da kaputt gehen? Was passiert da? Warum? Oder warte, lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Lass mich fragen.
Schuld an all dem sind die ersten Programmierer vor fast 40 Jahren.
Wer ist schuld?
Die ersten Programmierer, wie wir gerade gehört haben. Das ist immer noch so. Du hast ja gerade mit dem Jahr-2000-Problem angefangen. Wir werden ein Jahr 2038... Das hab ich noch gar nicht gesagt, aber darüber werden wir auch sprechen. Das Problem ist, Zeit muss man ja zählen.
Im Computer.
Im Computer. Man muss ja nachrechnen, wie spät es jetzt gerade so ist. Und dazu zählt man. Und in der Regel fängt man irgendwann an zu zählen und sagt, okay, jetzt hier ist Null. Und dann zählt man hoch. Eins, zwei, drei, vier und so weiter und so fort.
Ist das wie bei Funkuern? Da steht irgendwo in Frankfurt, glaube ich, so eine Atomuhr. Ich war als Kind total fasziniert davon, dass es da eine Atomuhr gibt, wo Atome gegen eine Glocke springen und die Zeit irgendwie angeben. Und dann wird das an die Funkuhr ausgestrahlt. Das ist bei Computer nicht so. Die regeln das intern.
Ja, die haben meistens Quarze für die Zeitsteuerung. Allerdings modernerweise werden sie tatsächlich von Atomuhen mit der präzisen Zeit gespeist. Da gibt es Protokolle darüber, wie man über das Netzwerk eine aktuelle Zeit bekommen kann, relativ genau.
Aber der Computer fragt jetzt nicht jede Sekundenbruchtheit, sondern alle x Minuten oder sowas.
Ja, also jeder Computer hat seine eigene Uhr. So ein Quarz-Ossillator, der eine bestimmte Anzahl pro Sekunde schwingt. Und dann werden diese Schwingen geteilt, dass es genau einmal pro Sekunde so einen Puls gibt, damit hochgezählt werden kann. Und da diese Quarze nicht alle gleich sind, gibt es da Abweichungen. Und diese Abweichungen kann man korrigieren, indem man regelmäßig mal bei der Atomuhr, also auch in Braunschweig, nachfragt, wie spät es eigentlich gerade wirklich ist. Und dann sagt er irgendwie, naja, seitdem du gestern gefragt hast, ist eine halbe Sekunde mehr vergangen, als du dachtest. Und dann sagt er, oh, dann muss ich mal ein bisschen schneller zählen und ab und zu mal einen auslassen.
Okay, so und diese Zeit muss irgendwie intern im Gerät repräsentiert werden und da liegt dann irgendwann das Problem, was genau passiert da. Also warte, stelle ich jetzt die richtige Frage, wenn ich frage, wann haben wir angefangen zu zählen?
Im Prinzip ja, aber vielleicht nochmal, was das eigentliche Problem ist, bevor wir zu kommen, wann wir angefangen haben zu zählen, weil das ist ja unterschiedlich. Das Problem ist, dass so ein Computer ja nicht unendlich viel Speicher hat und insbesondere, wir haben es gerade gehört, die alten Programmierer sind schuld. Früher war der Speicher sehr, sehr knapp, ne? Heutzutage, wenn man eine WhatsApp-Nachricht rausschickt, dann werden da mehr Daten durch die Gegend geschickt, als in den 70er Jahren ein Computer überhaupt Speicher hatte insgesamt. Und dann...
Du hast keine WhatsApp-Leute. Andere Diskussion.
Ja, es gibt Schlimmeres, aber es gibt auch viel Besseres. Es gibt immer Schlimmeres. Jedenfalls haben Sie sich damals gedacht, und dann fangen wir vielleicht mal mit dem Jahr-2000-Problem an. So eine Jahreszahl ist ja ganz schön lang. Erste, erste 1970, zweite, erste 1970, dritte, erste 1970. Da ist ja immer diese 19 drin, das kann man da weglassen. Wir nehmen bloß die letzten beiden Stellen. Das machen ja viele Leute auch noch gerne, wenn sie irgendwo unterschreiben. Heute ist der 23.5. 18. Jeder weiß, damit ist 2018 gemeint. Das haben sie sich damals auch gedacht. Das weiß doch jeder, wenn ich da 75 hinschreibe, dass doch 1975 gemeint ist. Und dann haben sie gesagt, mit den 19, die speichern waren nicht mit. Da haben wir zwei Ziffern gespart. Das ist viel, wenn man das mal hochrechnet. Das sind Tausende von Mark. Und deswegen haben sie das gemacht. Und denen war natürlich klar, dass 1999, das irgendwann vorbei ist, der Spaß, wenn es dann auf 2000 umspringt, der Computer da plötzlich 00 im Speicher zu stehen hat.
Warte, das war denen klar und sie haben es trotzdem gemacht?
Das ist alles 30 Jahre weg. Das ist doch eeeewig.
Okay, warte mal, da würde mich schon an der Stelle interessieren. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, wir müssen nachher nochmal erklären, warum das 2038, was ja eine völlig krumme Zahl zum Problem ist. Wir vergessen Euch nicht, Leute, wir machen das noch.
Wir fangen mal mit dem einfachen Beispiel an, was verständlich ist.
Ich glaube andersrum, was einfacher gewesen, aber egal. Was mich jetzt interessieren würde ist, weiß man in der Legende, ob die Programmierer gesagt haben, ja naja, also irgendwie zwei Zahlen reichen, oder ob die Manager gesagt haben, Leute, programmiert das möglichst zeiteffizient, weil dann können wir Geld sparen.
Ich denke, man weiß es nicht, aber es ist auch sozusagen eine naheliegende Entscheidung. Da kam ja nicht irgendwann der globale Programmier-Superdiktator und hat gesagt, ihr müsst das alles so machen, sondern viele Leute sind unabhängig voneinander auf die Idee gekommen, dass man diese beiden weil es doch sparen kann. Das konnten sie sich einfach nicht vorstellen, dass die Software, die sie da heute schreiben, in 30 Jahren noch läuft. Du musst überlegen, 1970 war die Raumfahrt-Epoche, Computer gab es gerade erst so.
Lustigerweise, hast du das letzte Chaos-Radio gehört?
Nee.
Da ging es um Banken. Da habe ich exakt diesen Satz gehört. Die Leute konnten sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass die Software dann noch läuft.
Das wusste man nicht. Und in den 60ern, Mondlandung und so, das war alles ein paar Jahre später. Die ganze Raumfahrt in den 60ern hat überhaupt erst die Integrationsdichte gebracht bei den Schaltkreisen, dass man mal größere Computer bauen konnte und sich mehr als vier Computer auf der ganzen Welt durchsetzen konnte. Das war alles super frisch und super neu. Das haben die sich nicht gedacht. Das haben sie sich nicht vorstellen können, dass in 30 Jahren alles noch da ist.
Dann gab es aber irgendwann das Problem.
Dann gab es irgendwann das Problem.
Das Problem war dann einfach, dass bis jetzt niemand daran gedacht hatte, dass ja möglicherweise diese zwei Zahlen zu Ende sind.
Genau. Wie gesagt, die Leute wussten das wahrscheinlich schon. Dann war es 1980, dann 1990, dann 1995. Diese Software lief immer noch. Dann kamen die ersten Programminen und meinten, du Chef, wir müssen aber was machen.
Warte mal. Ich habe die Geschichte nicht mehr ganz im Kopf. Die These ist sozusagen, Mitte 1999 haben die ersten Leute angefangen, ernsthaft drüber nachzuarbeiten. Aber Cliffhanger, darüber reden wir später. Und jetzt, wo wir wissen, was das eine Problem ist, erklärst du, was das andere Problem ist. Warum haben wir am 19. Januar 2038 um 4.14 Uhr und ein paar Sekunden, das ist ja, weißt du, zwei Zahlen, das ist jetzt eine Stelle zu wenig, das kann ich sehr einfach verstehen. Warum es an dieser Stelle passiert, ist ja nicht so doll offensichtlich.
Nicht ganz so einfach, da muss man ein bisschen weiter ausholen. Unsere genagten Zuhörer sicherlich wissen, arbeiten Computer mit so Bits, Nullen und Einsen. Diese Nullen und Einsen werden zusammengefasst zu Bits, zu Words oder zu D-Words oder zu Quad-Words.
Das sind einfach immer längere Ansammlungen von Nullen und Einsen?
Immer längere Ansammlungen von Nullen und Einsen. Und zwar immer schön in zweier Potenzen in der Anzahl. 8 Bits sind ein Byte, damit kann man so einen Buchstabe darstellen. Früher konnte man damit auch zwei Ziffern darstellen. Ein Jahr passte in einen Byte rein, wenn man das als eine BCD-Darstellung dargestellt hat. Und jetzt gab es in den 70ern diese Programmierer bei AT&T, denen ein bisschen langweilig war. Dann haben sie angefangen, Space Wars zu spielen. Und dann kam irgendwann auf einem Multicsystem. Und dann kam irgendwann ihr Manager und meinte irgendwie, ich habe gerade die Abrechnung vom Rechenzentrum geguckt, ihr habt irgendwie für 75 Dollar Space Wars gespielt, das geht aber so nicht. Dann meinten die, na gut. Dann stand so ein Mini-Computer in der Ecke. Dann haben sie angefangen, für ein Mini-Computer sich ein kleines Betriebssystem zu bauen mit einem kleinen Programmiersprächchen. Und da das Space Wars drauf zu portieren, damit der Chef nicht immer meckert, wenn sie zocken in der Arbeitszeit. Und das damals, das große System mit der Abrechnung, das hieß Multics. Das war ein großes und mächtiges System auf groß und mächtigen Computern.
Aber stopp, ich glaube, das muss man mal erklären. Dass es eine Zeit gab, wo nicht, du sozusagen dich an einen Arbeitsplatz gesetzt hast, dein Rechner aufgeklappt hast und angefangen hast zu arbeiten, sondern es gab in einem großen Gebäude ein riesiges Gerät. Und das war die Steuerungseinheit für den noch viel größeren Computer, der über Arbeitsplätze angesteuert wurde und wo man Rechenzeit buchen musste. Genau, genau, genau.
Wo dann also Priester in weißen Gewand standen und man eher fürchtig seinen Stapel Lochkarten hingetragen hat, bis man dran war. Und dann hat also der Priester mit seinen Handschuhen und dem weißen Kittel die Lochkarten in die große Maschine gelegt und ganz doll gerattert. Wir haben in alte Filme geguckt, wo es die ganze Zeit blinkt und rattert. So war ein Computer früher wirklich. Und dann hat man also zwei Stunden später die einzelne Ausgabe Error zurückgekriegt. Und dann musste man durch seine Lochkarten durchgehen, gucken, was das Problem ist, und durfte dann in drei Tagen wiederkommen, um es noch mal auszuprobieren. So war ein Computer funktioniert.
Die Zeit war sehr begrenzt, deswegen hatten diese Programmierer das Problem mit ihrem Chef. Dann haben sie aber angefangen mit dem kleinen Rechner, den es doch auch schon gab, der wahrscheinlich nicht so doll viel konnte.
Der konnte nicht so doll viel. Jeder Schultaschenrechner hat heute wesentlich mehr Leistung, jede Armandur. Aber der Vorteil war, das war so ein Minicomputer. Der war so groß wie so ein Kühlschrank etwa. Den haben sie mal gebaut, da konnte man einen Tag mitmachen. Und sie haben sich gedacht, da machen wir jetzt selber was. Wie gesagt, auf dem großen Computer lief ein System namens Multics. Und als Witz haben sie es dann Unix genannt. Weil es war ja für den kleinen Computer, nicht für den großen Computer. Also eins statt viele. Und dann passierte ein historischer Unfall in der Computergeschichte. Weil irgendwie, das lag da halt rum, es hat sich ja auch niemand für bezahlt, es war eher so Forschung. Dann haben die Universitäten angefragt, sag mal, wir haben ja auch so einen Minicomputer stehen, was habt ihr denn da drauf zu laufen? Na, wir haben ja so einen Unix programmiert, das könnt ihr haben. Und dann haben sie angefangen, an die Universitäten ein Sourcecode zu verteilen. Und so ist Unix ein sehr populäres Betriebssystem geworden. Und zwar so populär, dass bis zum heutigen Tage die Betriebssysteme, die auf unseren Computern, auf unseren Telefonen laufen, alle von diesem System abstammen.
Auch Windows?
Auch Windows. Also indirekt, es ist nicht der selbe Sourcecode. Aber die Ideen von Unix wurden von damals Deck von Digital Equipment, vom S.
Also es ist nicht der selbe Programmiercode, aber die Technologien werden da drin auch verwendet. Das heißt, es wird auch die Zeit auf dieselbe Art und Weise repräsentiert?
Auf ähnliche Art und Weise. Bei Windows muss ich jetzt tatsächlich nachgucken. Da haben Sie bestimmt irgendwann zwischendrin mal was anderes getan. Windows hatte lustigerweise einen ganz ähnlichen Bug, nämlich den Reboot nach 32 Tagen Bug. Komme ich gleich dazu, wenn ich erzählt habe, was eigentlich das Problem bei Unix ist, erzähle ich, was das Problem bei Windows war, bis es gefixt haben. Jedenfalls saßen da diese Menschen und es war so ein Computer, der 8-Bit-Bytes hatte. Auch das war damals nicht immer normal, aber es war halt so. Dann brauchten sie ein bequemes Vielfaches davon. Dann haben sie sich überlegt, wie zählen wir denn jetzt Zeit? Dann haben sie gesagt, einmal pro Sekunde einen Zähler hochzählen, also Sekunden zählen ist gut. Wir fangen mal bei 0 an zu zählen und wir legen die 0 fest auf den ersten, ersten 1970 0 Uhr. Damit lässt sich also sozusagen die Uhrzeit, Datum plus Uhrzeit, Sekunden genau, in 32 Bit darstellen.
Das sind dann, ach, 4 Byte.
Das sind 4 Byte, ja, in 4 Byte. Also was man dann, also klar, wenn man es ausschreibt, ist es natürlich wesentlich mehr Byte, aber es ist dann schön kompakt. Für damalige Verhältnisse, RAM war teuer, eine kompakte Darstellung.
Also das heißt sozusagen, wann immer der Computer nicht die Uhr, also die, oder man als Hoff, wenn die Uhrzeit wissen will, fragt sie, was ist die Uhrzeit und bekommt dann zurück an eine 32-Bit-Zahl. Das sind die Sekunden, die vergangen sind seit dem 1.1.1970 Mitternacht. Genau. Ach so, warte, es sind 32 Bit. Was ist die maximale Zahl indizimal?
4 Milliarden. 4 Milliarden irgendwas.
Aha, und das heißt also am 19.1.2038 4 Uhr 14.07 ist es alle?
Die Wahrheit ist noch viel trauriger. Die Wahrheit ist noch viel trauriger? Am 19.1. sind erst 2 Milliarden Sekunden verbraucht, nämlich 2 hoch 31. Das 32 Bit ist das Vorzeichen.
Also warum ich lache ist, wenn man die Uhrzeit so repräsentiert, wie Du es gerade erklärt hast, braucht man in dem Fall das Vorzeichen ja gar nicht.
Das ist richtig, man braucht das Vorzeichen nicht.
Man hat es aber damals mitgenommen, weil 32 Bit sind ja so viel.
Es war bequemer, in Zahlen zu rechnen, die ein Vorzeichen haben, weil sonst hätte man ja umwandeln müssen. Das wäre dann wieder langsam gewesen.
Okay, verstehe. Wenn man sich so Binärzahlen vorstellt, das sind ja diese Bits, die 0 und 1 sein können. Und je höher diese Zahl geht, desto mehr Nullen werden zu 1. Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt wären sozusagen alle Stellen eine 1. Und dann würde man plus 1 sagen, und dann ist es wieder bei 0. Das heißt für das Gerät, wie ich es gerade in der Eingangsszene beschrieben habe, wäre dann wieder der 1.1.1970 0 Uhr.
Der 1.1.1970 0 Uhr, so ist das. Sogenannter Überlauf. Das Problem haben nicht alle Programmersprachen. Manche sind clever genug. Aber der Computer selber rechnet nicht auf natürlichen Zahlen, wie man sie aus der Schule kennt, sondern mit einem begrenzten Zahlenbereich. Nämlich genau den Zahlen, die man in so einem Word oder was auch immer darstellen kann, je nachdem was für ein Datentyp ist. Der läuft irgendwann über. Genau das passiert da. Der läuft diese 32-Bit-Wert über. Und dann ist wieder 1970.
So, jetzt habe ich vier Sachen gesagt in der Einführung, die Konsequenzen davon sein könnten. Aber das war jetzt eher so, ich sag mal, Privatfernsehen. Das Smartphone zeigt an, er ist der 1.01.1970.
Ist das realistisch? Mit ein bisschen Glück wird das nicht passieren. Also die Frage ist halt, wir wissen ja von dem Problem.
Ne, ne, ne, dazu kommen wir später. Jetzt erstmal davon auszugehen, niemand guckt sich das Problem an. Alle denken, das wird schon jemand anders machen. Verantwortungsdiffusion im großen Maßstab. Und das passiert so.
Dann kann das passieren. Also die Smartphones, die wir haben, die sind, also entweder sind es Apple-Telefone oder es sind Android-Telefone. Und Apple ist ein Unix-artiges Betriebssystem. Und Android ist auch ein Unix-artiges Betriebssystem. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, dass da an vielen Stellen schon der Umzug auf 64-Bit vollzogen ist. Man muss schon ein sehr, sehr altes Smartphone haben, was noch nicht 64-Bit ist. Und dann bei der Gelegenheit wird dann auch dieser Zähler ein bisschen größer gemacht.
Ach so, das wird einfach weitergezählt. Nur, dass man sozusagen mehr Platz hat.
Genau, da hat man dann mehr Platz. Dann läuft das irgendwann bei 64-Bit. Also so alt wären wir alle nicht, wenn das überläuft. Also bei Telefonen wirst du vermutlich Glück haben. Theoretisch, vom Mechanismus her könnte es passieren, aber dann müsstest du schon ein uraltes 32-Bit-Smartphone haben und das in den nächsten 20 Jahren nicht updaten.
Und wir sprechen dann auch so von in 18 Jahren. Das heißt, da wären die Telefoner wahrscheinlich wirklich alle. Okay, also bei Telefonen, dann war das schon mal falsch. Das nächste ist, da habe ich es noch nicht erzählt, aber eingeschoben, das heißt für Rechner gilt wahrscheinlich dasselbe. Also Rechner, die wir zu Hause benutzen, mein Laptop, ich weiß nicht, ob es noch Gaming-Rechner gibt, 2038.
Genau, da sind die Bestrebungen ja auch schon relativ weit. Alles, was 32-Bit ist eigentlich zu killen und auf 64-Bit umzustellen.
Okay, also nur um das noch mal ganz klar zu sagen, das heißt an der Stelle wird nicht das Problem geklärt, dass diese Zeit in einer Art und Weise repräsentiert wird, wo irgendwann der Speicherplatz alle ist, sondern dann wird einfach gesagt, dann werfen wir einfach mehr Speicherplatz drauf.
Genau, genau, genau. Wir leisten uns in den Zeiten der TeraBytes den dekadenten Luxus tatsächlich 8-Bytes zu verwenden, um einen Zeitstempel zu speichern.
Das ist nicht viel, aber es ist trotzdem das kapitalistische Prinzip.
Es kann natürlich auch auf solchen Computern trotzdem Probleme auftauchen.
Warte mal, vielleicht ist es auch unfair von mir. Gibt es überhaupt eine andere Lösung für dieses Problem? Also eine andere Art, Zeit zu repräsentieren auf eine Art und Weise, die nicht abhängig ist vom Speicherplatz und nicht irgendwann alles?
Nee, du kannst natürlich sagen, nimm dir halt so viel Speicher, wie du brauchst. Und dann ist auch absehbar, dann kannst du ausrechnen mit meinen physikalischen Konstanten. Auf jeden Fall steigt die Entropie des Universums ja so weit, dass irgendwann sozusagen kein Leben mehr möglich ist, weil das Universum quasi den Hitzetod stirbt und du zwei Zustände nicht mehr unterscheiden kannst. Du kannst nicht mehr zuverlässig eine Null von einer Eins unterscheiden, weil das thermische Rauschen im Universum zu groß geworden ist.
Aber bis dahin wär's ne Weile.
Das ist ne Weile. Das kannst du eigentlich ausrechnen, kannst du sagen, welche Zählgenauigkeit brauch ich, wenn wir sagen, es gibt ja ne kürzeste Zeit in der Physik, die so bei 10 hoch minus 50 Sekunden in der größten Ordnung liegt. Also wenn man sagt, um die 10 hoch minus 50 nehmen wir 50 Bit, dann können wir schon mal die kleinsten, möglichst auftretende Zeit präzise zählen. Und dann nehmen wir nochmal die nächsten 50 oder 60 Bit, wie lange wir brauchen, bis das Universum tot ist. Also ich glaube, mit 128 Bit als Zeitzähler kommen wir auf jeden Fall aus. Das sind wir safe.
Du hast gerade gesagt, es ist zwar 64 oder vielleicht 128 Bit, wir werden sehen, aber trotzdem kann es zu Problemen kommen.
Ja, weil es ja nicht nur um das Betriebssystem geht, um die Zeit des Computers selbst, sondern auch um die Dateien, die du auf deinem Computer gespeichert hast. Es gibt ja Dateiformate. Und auch auf einem 64-Bit-System kann es sein, dass irgendein althergebrachtes Dateiformat, Dateisysteme betrifft das auch, dass da die Zeit drin falsch gespeichert wird. Und dass am Ende deine Rente falsch berechnet wird.
Warte mal, das heißt, wenn ich eine Datei abspeichere, dass es irgendwie ein Dokument, ein Punkt-Doc-Dokument sein, dann ist also die, wann ist dieses Dokument gespeichert worden, ist die eine Sache?
Auch die Zeiten, die drinstehen.
Ach so, wenn ich so eine Tabellenkalkulation habe.
Zum Beispiel, ja, oder eine Datenbank, oder sagen wir da eine Rentenabrechnung.
Meine Renten, du meinst also nicht auf meinem persönlichen Computer, sondern auch an offiziellen Stellen?
Genau, genau, genau, weil da ist es ja ganz genauso. Der Typ ist schon 1970 in Rente gegangen. Ja, der hat vor allen Dingen 1970 aufgehört zu arbeiten. Das macht also minus 30 Rentenjahre. Das sind also wie viele negative Rentenpunkte. So was kann passieren.
Das heißt also nicht nur die Computer müssen modernisiert werden, sondern auch Datenbanken im weitesten Sinne.
Die Software, also alles was sozusagen anfängt mit Zeit zu rechnen, ist potentiell betroffen. Deine Kreditverträge. Vielleicht hast du Glück und der rechnet irgendwie, wenn du pro Jahr 3% Zinsen auf deinen Kredit zahlst, dann zahlst du also für minus 100 Jahre.
Wenn ich den Kredit 2000 aufgenommen habe, aber jetzt ist es wieder 1970, wir kommen durcheinander. In meiner Einführungsszene ist da noch ein Flugzeug. Es war dunkel und kalt erst in der Wohnung.
Dunkel und kalt.
Da sind ja diese Horrors aneinander. Strom fällt aus, die Heizung geht nicht mehr, weil irgendwas mit dem Internet off things ist.
Ist das realistisch? Tatsächlich ja. Und tatsächlich sind da auch viele Probleme, wo nichts so einfach ranzukommen ist wie an einen Rechner, der irgendwo steht. Also unsere PCs werden regelmäßig geupdatet, die Telefone usw.
usf.
Aber so ziemlich alles, wo Elektronen durchfließen, hat ja mittlerweile eine Computersteuerung. Und diese Betriebssysteme da drin, die werden eher selten geupdatet. Also die laufen in der Industrieanlage auch gerne mal 20, 30, 40 Jahre durch. Oh, die fest dann keiner an. Und da können interessante Effekte passieren. Also es gibt viele Steuerungen, gerade so Echtzeitsteuerungen, die darauf angewiesen sind, dass die Zeit linear hoch zählt. Also stell dir einfach mal vor, du hast, keine Ahnung, du hast da so einen Topf mit so einer chemischen Reaktion drin. Und damit dir das nicht explodiert, musst du pro Zeiteinheit eine bestimmte Menge von einer Flüssigkeit reingießen, damit die Reaktion kontrolliert abläuft.
Dann würde ich den Thema ja immer wieder auf Null stellen, aber eben.
Dazu musst du das erstmal wissen, dazu musst du das erstmal reingucken können. Die Situation ist, da läuft so ein Stückchen Kot. Dieses Stückchen Kot wird regelmäßig getriggert. Das guckt nach. Seit wann bin ich eigentlich das letzte Mal gelaufen? Das ist 823 Millisekunden her und ich muss pro Sekunde diese Menge da reinkippen. Also irgendwie mal 1000 durch 823. Und dann dosiert er das da rein. Und dann stellt er sich wieder den Wecker und dann wacht er eine Sekunde später auf und sagt, diesmal sind 1105 Millisekunden vergangen. Und der wacht plötzlich auf und dann sind minus zwei Milliarden Sekunden vergangen. Dann multipliziert er das mit seiner Menge, die er pro Sekunde reintun muss und dann kommt irgendein Wert bei raus. Und das tut er in seine Pumpe und seine Pumpe sagt irgendwie, ne.
Warte mal, dann ist also nicht nur realistisch, dass das Heizkraftwerk und das Stromkraftwerk ausgefallen sind, sondern auch die Exposuren am Horizont nicht beschrieben habe, könnte passieren?
Das ist ein völlig realistisches Szenario. Wenn Du dieses Problem ernsthaft angiehst, musst Du Dir Industrie-Controlsysteme angucken, und zwar irgendwie bis in die einzelnen Reihen und insbesondere kritische Prozesse. Alles, was BOOM machen kann.
Weil, also, dass das so ist, logisch. Aber wird das auch gemacht?
Na, das hoffen wir mal. Können wir vielleicht mal anfangen, über das Jahr-2000-Problem zu reden?
Warte, im Jahr-2000 war es ja so. Und nun wird die Zeit knapp. So knapp, dass der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten es zur Chefsache erklärt hat. Diese Auslöse, die wir heute mit dabei haben, sind übrigens aus Neues die Computershow aus dem November 99. Also kurz bevor das Jahr-2000-Problem zuzuschlagen drohte. Da war es also Chefsache. Zumindest dann Ende 99, was relativ spät ist.
Ja, das war vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen zu spät, das zur Chefsache zu machen. Es gibt ja bei diesem Jahr-2000-Problem teilweise die Meinung, das war ja alles gar nicht so schlimm, da ist ja gar nichts passiert, das war ja alles nur heil. Und wenn man näher hinguckt, ist die Wahrheit, dass genau deswegen nichts passiert ist, weil viele Leute das Problem ernst genommen haben und rechtzeitig gegengesteuert haben. Es gab auch ein paar, die haben es zu spät bemerkt. Also eins meiner Lieblingsbeispiele, musst du dir vorstellen. Es ist der 31.12.1999. Der Ort ist das Berghain, das zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht das Berghain war, sondern eine Ruine eines Kraftwerkes in Berlin. Andreas und Freunde hatten halt nichts anderes zu tun, als über den Zaun zu klettern, in diese Industrieruine einzubrechen, auf das Dach obendrauf zu steigen, sich von da das Feuerwerk anzugucken. Und pünktlich um Mitternacht fuhren die Feuerwehren aus der daneben liegenden Feuerwache, guckten alle ein bisschen bedröppelt und fingen an, Streife zu fahren in der Stadt. Was ist da passiert? Das Leitsystem der Feuerwehr war auch so ein alter Computer, wo die Notfalleinsätze, ja, du rufst irgendwie eins ins Null an, sagst, es brennt. Dann haben die ja einen Computer, wo sie eingeben, Lagemeldungen, da wird das übermittelt usw. So ein Leitsystem. Und das hatten die damals auch schon. Und dann kriegt da also ein befreundeter Hacker, Mitte Oktober 1999, einen Anruf von der Berliner Feuerwehr, sie hätten da so einen Computer, ob er mal gucken könnte, wegen Jahr 2000. Der meinte irgendwie, sechs Wochen ihr spinnt, das mach ich nicht. War auch ganz gut so, weil wer immer sich das Projekt ein Land gezogen hat, hat es halt in den Sand gesetzt. Und die Feuerwehr hatte einfach zum 1.1.2000 in Berlin kein Leitsystem mehr und ist Streife gefahren.
Holy shit! Wow, aber dann gab es halt irgendwie doch so Leute wie die hier. Jeden Morgen zieht Justin Kelly in den Kampf.
An der Tafel vorbei, auf der seine Mission beschrieben ist.
Justin soll eine Bombe entschärfen. Eine Bombe entschärfen, das haben ja doch ein paar Leute gemacht.
Ja, da ist viel Arbeit getan worden. Das war bestimmt teilweise auch sehr schmutzig. Für manche Leute war es auch sehr lukrativ.
Je später man den Auftrag angenommen habe, desto mehr hat es gekostet.
Ja, überleg mal, du hast in den 60ern oder 70ern einen AVM-Mainframe-Assembler programmiert. Und bist dann in den 90ern in den Ruhestand gegangen. Dann rufen die an und sagen irgendwie, kannst du mal aus der Rente kommen, wir haben da so ein Problem. Da sagst du, das ist nicht mein Problem, ich bin in Rente. Dann fangen die an, dir vorzurechnen, wie viel man am Tag verdienen kann. Dann sagst du, na gut, ich wollte eh schon mal so eine Kreuzfahrt und ein neues Auto brauche ich auch, okay.
Wow, aber was genau musste man dann da machen?
Also es gab verschiedene Ansätze, das Problem zu lösen. Der Schwierigkeitsgrad wird halt umso größer, je älter, obskurer das System ist, je weniger Sourcecode man noch hat und je weniger Leute man findet, die das Programm neu übersetzen können.
Warte mal, es gab tatsächlich Maschinen, denen Programme ausgeführt wurden, für die der Sourcecode in Zweifel gar nicht mehr verfügbar ist?
Ja, das ist Kapitalismus. Überleg dir, du lässt ein Software programmieren, dann kriegst du dein Programm ausgeliefert und die Firma, die es geschrieben hat, geht pleite. Zehn Jahre später. Und dann nochmal zehn Jahre später stellst du fest, dass in deinem Programm ein Problem ist.
Okay.
Dann wird es halt schmutzig.
Was macht man in so einem Fall?
Man packt seinen Disassembler aus und dann macht man da so ein Reverse-Engineering drauf.
Das heißt, man nimmt ein Programm, das im Computer der Zeit läuft und setzt ein anderes Programm drauf und das versucht, herauszufinden, was die einzigen Programmierschritte sind, übersetzt das in so einen Maschinencode und den muss man dann lesen können?
Ja, nicht zur Laufzeit, das geht auch. Also es wäre dann ein Debugger. Disassembler heißt erstmal, man nimmt das Programm, so ein Punkt Excel. Und das wird zurück in für Menschen lesbaren Maschinencode übersetzt. Dann guckt sich das einer an.
Aber für Menschen lesbarer Maschinencode ist schon ein Euphemismus für jemand, der sehr viel Ahnung hat, kann möglicherweise verstehen, was da steht.
Es sind immerhin nicht mehr Nullen und Einsen. Da steht dann sowas wie RepMovSB. Und dann ist da ein Sport für wenige, die sind auch entsprechend gut bezahlt. Das sind Leute, die ansonsten in ihrer Freizeit Kopierschutzsysteme knacken oder Exploits für Bugs in Windows schreiben. Das ist so die Zielgruppe. Und die können natürlich auch mit einem Programm, zu dem kein Sourcecode mehr da ist, einen Patch bauen.
Worin bestand der Patch? Dass man gesagt hat, wir benutzen jetzt für die Jahreszahlen doch vier Stellen?
Das ist die gute Möglichkeit. Wenn du ausreichende Flexibilität hast, dass du da vier Stellen einführen kannst, dann hast du quasi schon gewonnen. Sourcecode, irgendwie machst du eine Änderung, änderst das Datenformat. Da wird es ein bisschen eklig. Du musst ja nicht nur das Programm ändern, du musst auch die dazu passenden Daten ändern. Und wenn du dann in der Lage bist, dir so ein Konvertierungsprogramm zu schreiben, und dann irgendwie, beliebt ist immer zu Ostern, weil da sind drei Bankfeiertage auf einmal das Skript durchlaufen lassen, was deine alten Daten nimmt, in das neue Format konvertiert, und dann wird hinterher die neue Software hochgefahren, dann halten alle die Luft an, dass es noch weiter funktioniert. Das ist so der gute Fall. Was sie teilweise getan haben, ist so eine Art Sliding Window, dass sie gesagt haben, sie sind beim Speichern von zwei Stellen geblieben und haben aber nur die Ausgabe-Routinen uminterpretiert. Also wenn dann sozusagen, wenn da 00 im Datensatz steht und der das druckt, dass er nicht 1900 schreibt, sondern sagt irgendwie, na gut, wenn es irgendwie kleiner als 70 ist, dann ist wahrscheinlich 2000 irgendwas gemeint. Und dass dann irgendwie 2000 ausgegeben wird, obwohl 00 gespeichert wird, das schiebt natürlich das Problem nur nach hinten raus. Alle paar Jahrzehnte hat man das Problem dann wieder und man hat dann auch noch das Pech, dass man ein individuelles Problem hat. Also kein Problem, wo die ganze Welt darauf aufmerksam wird, weil das Jahr-2000-Problem, sondern dann hast du halt ein Jahr-2040-Problem oder ein Jahr-2070-Problem und weißt es nicht.
Also warte mal, das heißt, es ist theoretisch denkbar, dass, du hast ja gerade über diese Industriestellungssysteme gesprochen, wo halt so Code drin ist, der nicht so oft angeguckt wird, dass an irgendeiner Stelle eine völlig arbitriere Entscheidung getroffen wurde. Man hat gesagt, naja, 65 ist ja auch eine schöne Zahl. Und dann ist es, wow. Das klingt ja hervorragend. Man kann also zwei Sachen sagen. Man hat damals gesagt, also vier Zahlen, das ist die gute Lösung. Dann baue ich mir eine beliebige Grenze ein und sage so, ab dann war wahrscheinlich nach 2000 gemeint, schätze ich mal, so mein Daumen gepeilt.
Noch was?
Oder sind das quasi die beiden?
Das sind so die grob die wichtigsten Lösungen.
Okay. Und das hat ja tatsächlich auch...
Ach so, genau. Es gibt natürlich noch wegschmeißen und komplett neu machen als Lösung. Einstampfen, neu programmieren.
Ich suche gerade noch was. Moment mal. Weil die Sache mit dem Jahr-2000-Problem war ja dann, dass es doch relativ gut funktioniert hat.
Guten Abend, meine Damen und Herren. Der Wechsel ins Jahr 2000 hat weltweit bisher keine nennenswerten Computerprobleme gebracht. Zentrale Bereiche wie die Wasser- und Energieversorgung, die Telefonnetze, das Bankungssystem und der Luft- und Bahnverkehr liefen reibungslos weiter. Experten hatten eindringlich vor einem Chaos gewarnt. Rechner, die mit zweistelligen Jahresangaben arbeiteten, könnten das Datum 2000 als 1900 interpretieren. Erst im Laufe des Jahres werde sich zeigen, ob die Systeme der Umstellung standhielten. Der Krisenstab der Bundesregierung sieht dagegen keine ernsthaften Schwierigkeiten mehr.
Also A, vielen Dank an die Leute, die sich ja mal drum gekümmert haben. B, werde ich schon hellhörig, wenn man sagt, keine nennenswerten Computerprobleme. Gab es denn Dinge, die passiert sind? Also wir haben ja gerade schon gehört, die Feuerwehr musste Streife fahren, weil sie zu spät Fachleute gefragt hat, ob sie es mal fixen können. Weißt Du noch von anderen Dingen, die da schiefgegangen sind?
Konkret kann ich dir jetzt nichts weiter berichten.
Also das heißt, es war schon relativ in Ordnung?
Also immer so Kleinigkeiten. Das lustigste, was ich gesehen habe, stand nicht 1900, sondern 19100.
Muss sehr sauber programmiert gewesen sein.
Alle programmierbar, aber immer sauber.
Du hast es ja auch vorhin schon gesagt, dass es im Jahr 2000 auch hinterher Leute gab, die gesagt haben, naja, ist ja nichts passiert, war anscheinend kein großes Problem. Ich höre das interessanterweise jetzt gerade im Zusammenhang mit Epidemien oder drohenden Pandemien, dass so Leute mutmaßen, naja, es wäre schon gut, wenn die Menschen sich vorbereiten. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist aber auch hoch, wenn das alle gut machen und dann nichts passiert, dass man hinterher sagt, so impfgegnermäßig, naja, ist doch immer alles gut gegangen bis jetzt. Wie ist denn da bei dem Jahr-2038-Problem gerade die Stimmung?
Also, das klingt halt noch verdammt weit weg. Das sind ja noch 18 Jahre.
Ist das wirklich so? Weil mir wurde gesagt, dass erste Probleme schon viel früher auftreten können.
Also es treten schon erste Probleme auf, nämlich bei solchen Programmen, die Berechnungen machen, die über das Jahr 2038 hinausgehen. Also wie bei der Rentenberechnung oder bei der O.
Okay, ich werde hellhörig.
Oder bei der Kriegberechnung. Bei was? Ja, alles, wo gerechnet werden muss über diesen Zeitpunkt hinaus. Wenn das intern halt mit diesem Zahlenformat arbeitet, hört das plötzlich auf zu funktionieren. In dem Moment, wo man halt in diesen Zeitbereich reinrechnet. Das heißt, schon heute können Probleme auftreten, die daran liegen, dass 2038 was überläuft.
Aber ist es dann einfach kaputt oder ist es, also Fehler können ja immer auf zwei Arten und Weisen passieren. Das eine ist sozusagen, oh, da ist ein Fehler, offensichtlich ist etwas kaputt, darum müssen wir uns kümmern. Und das andere ist ja, das läuft aus falsch, aber es kriegt erst mal keiner mit, weil es sieht alles richtig aus.
Ja, es kann alles passieren. Ich hatte ja vorhin das mit dem Windows erzählt, vielleicht als kleines Beispiel, wie die Bandbreite ist. Windows zählt die Zeit intern nicht in Sekunden, sondern in Millisekunden. Da wird da regelmäßig was hochgezählt. Und dann, wenn das Windows zu lange lief, so was wie länger als 32 Tage, 20 Millisekunden oder Mikrosekunden, ich muss gleich nochmal nachrechnen, ich habe extra einen Taschenrechner mitgebracht. Auf jeden Fall nach 32 Tagen ist das Windows abgestürzt. Wait. Wenn du den Rechner 32 Tage lang nicht gebootet hast, dann ist es abgestürzt. Manchmal ist Abstürzen durchaus wörtlich zu nehmen. Es gibt also ein Flugzeug eines großen amerikanischen Flugzeugherstellers, der in letzter Zeit deutlich aufgefallen ist, dass es mit der Qualität nicht mehr so gut geht. Und hört mit Eugen auf. Da gibt es eine Anweisung der FAA, dass man dieses Flugzeug, die sind ja die ganze Zeit unterwegs, die werden ja quasi nicht ausgeschaltet. Aber dieses Flugzeug, das muss alle 30 Tage mal ausgeschaltet werden. Und zwar aus genau demselben Grund, dass es nicht einfach abstürzt.
Der Fick. Warte mal, mal abgesehen davon, dass ich unfassbar erschüttert darüber bin, dass das überhaupt, also ich bin sozusagen, also es ist schon schlimm genug, dass so was überhaupt passiert. Aber dass dann die Ansage nicht lautet, zieht das Ding aus dem Verkehr und baut das gefälligst richtig, sondern bitte macht regelmäßig ein Reboot. Das macht mir schon Angst. Und zwar so viel, dass ich vergessen habe, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte. Flugzeuge, die abschützen. Das heißt auch, weil ich glaube, das macht man sich nicht immer klar bei diesen ganzen Computersachen, dass es einfach Dinge gibt, die funktionieren nicht, wenn die Computer darin nicht funktionieren. Weil man würde eigentlich denken, wenn das Flugzeug nicht die Zeit weiß, nicht so geil, aber fliegen kann es zur Not, auch ohne. Aber nein, kann es nicht.
Ja, es können Dinge passieren. Die Wirkmechanismen können die unterschiedlichsten sein. In dem Fall war es nicht die Zeit, die übergelaufen ist. Aber es ist eine schöne Geschichte, die auch mit dem Überlauf von Werten zu tun hat. Deswegen erzähle ich sie. Der Absturz der Ariane 5 beim ersten Flug. War das bemannt oder unbemannt? Das war zum Glück unbemannt. Das war der erste Testflug. Das Ding ist leider explodiert. Und zwar war die Ariane 5 größer, schneller und stärker als die Ariane 4. Und jetzt wurde aber Code aus der Ariane 4 mitverwendet. Und da war so ein kleines Stückchen Software, das irgendeine Berechnung durchgeführt hat. Und das wirklich Schlimme ist, dieses Stückchen Code wurde bei Ariane 5 nicht mehr wirklich gebraucht. Es lief einfach nur so mit. Und weil sie schneller flog, ist also dieser eine Wert übergelaufen. Weil es war nicht genug Platz für die Geschwindigkeit, die die Rakete erreicht hat. Und weil das sehr sorgfältig geschriebene Raumfahrtsoftware war, ist es also nicht einfach still und leise übergelaufen. Und dann ist was passiert oder nicht. Sondern das System hat ordnungsgemäß gemeldet, jo, hier ist ein Wert übergelaufen. Und da gab es eine Fehlerbehandlungsroutine, die hat gesagt irgendwie, da ist ein Fehler aufgetreten, den kenne ich nicht. Was machen wir denn jetzt? Notfall, Notfall, Notfall, wir sprengen jetzt die Rakete.
Das heißt, ein Stück Code, das Geschwindigkeit gemessen hat, die eigentlich niemand braucht an der Stelle, hat dann ausgelöst, dass die Rakete absichtlich zur Explosion gebracht wurde.
Die kontrollierte Sprengung als sozusagen letzte Sicherheitsmaßnahme für wir haben das System nicht mehr unter Kontrolle.
Wow, das ist bitter.
Und solche Geschichten können halt nahezu beliebig passieren, überall wo Computer drin sind, kann dir sowas passieren? Bei dem Jahr 2038 Problem.
Ich bin ein bisschen sprachlos, das macht eine große Angst. Aber wird dann jetzt schon dran gearbeitet?
Wahrscheinlich noch nicht mit dem ausreichenden Nachdruck, außer dass sozusagen, wenn man die Gelegenheit hat, ein System auf 64-Bit umzuziehen, dann ist das immer ein Grund, neben vielen anderen das zu tun. Dann ist man das einfach los.
Okay, das heißt aber, wenn wir jetzt von Maschinen reden, die groß genug sind, wie ist das denn bei diesen ganzen Steuerungsmechanismen oder Steuerungs-Hardware, die in Kraftwerken drin sind, ist man da mittlerweile auch soweit, dass Speicherplatz egal ist, also das haben die 64-Bit nicht wehtun oder gibt es noch Systeme, die darauf angewiesen sind? Ich habe ja so eine Smartwatch irgendwie am Handgelenk, die wird wahrscheinlich auch 64-Bit sein, oder?
Ja, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, aber vermutlich schon.
Es würde dich nicht überraschen, wenn es so wäre, weil die Technik sozusagen weiter vorkommt.
Es würde mich nicht überraschen, es kann aber auch sein, dass es noch ein 32-Bit-System ist.
Aber selbst wenn es so wäre, ist es eine Frage der Zeit, dass man sagt, in drei Jahren sind die auch so.
Aber deine Waschmaschine ist mit Sicherheit noch kein 64-Bit-System. Also gerade in dem Embattled-Bereich, da ist halt richtig Arbeit und da muss man sich auch drum kümmern. Also alles, was Steuerungssysteme ist, was halt 20 Jahre unbeachtet in der Ecke steht. Ein Freund von mir guckt sich ja beruflich gelegentlich Computer an, macht so Audits und der erzählte auch, er war mal in einer Chemiefabrik, hat sich da so Rechnern geguckt und da stand in der Ecke so eine alte PDP. Das ist irgendwie dieser Rechner, wo irgendwie die Herrschaften damals ihr Unix entwickelt haben, weil sie spielen wollten. Das war auch so eine PDP, die stand da also rum. Und dann fragte er, was ist denn das? Weiß keiner so genau, aber der Typ, der mein Vorgänger war, hat gesagt, ich soll es nicht ausschalten, das wäre nicht so gut.
Was?
Wie lange ist der schon nicht mehr im Unternehmen? So zehn Jahre. Okay. Dann haben sie sich anguckt, was das Ding macht. Das war dann tatsächlich die Steuerung für dieses Chemiesystem. Wenn es ausgefallen wäre, wäre die Plastik in den Leitungen hart geworden. Man hätte das Werk abreißen müssen für einen dreistelligen Medikumbetrag. Immerhin wäre es nicht explodiert, aber... Was? Ja, so was passiert da draußen. Rechner werden vergessen, auch dass sie wichtig sind werden vergessen. Da wird dann so kargokaltmäßig gesagt, oh, fass es nicht an.
Also ich habe neulich sozusagen, von einer, also völlig undramatisch, also undramatisch in dem Kontext von der entstehen Millionen Schäden, aber so kleine, kleinere Society, die Dinge getan hat und die umgezogen sind. Und ich habe für die ab und zu was gearbeitet. Dann habe ich gefragt, so, hey, letztes Jahr hattet ihr noch dieses, also es war schon ein bisschen klobig, aber es war dieses Online-System, was wir benutzt haben. Die sind so, ja, als die umgezogen sind, ist der Server irgendwie weggekommen. Keiner wusste, wo, wo soll auf welchem Rechner das läuft. Wir haben einfach ein paar Rechner aussortiert, weil wir sind ja umgezogen, kann man ja mal auch, da weiß ich nicht mehr drauf, und das finde ich schon witzig.
Das ist aber nicht schlimm, aber das geht auch im Industrie-Maßstab.
Aber das, ich verstehe das nicht. Ich bin ja Fan von, dass man ab und zu da hinkommt, dass man sagt, vielleicht müssen wir Kapitalismus anzünden. Ist das hier auch der Fall? Also wie kann ich denn eine Firma betreiben und zulassen, dass so was passiert?
Ja, weißt du, wenn du für Quartalsergebnisse verantwortlich bist und nicht für das, was in zehn Jahren passiert, wenn du daran gemessen wirst als Manager, dann sind halt Sachen schwierig. Das betrifft auch andere Steuerungssysteme. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es anders wird, wenn man irgendeine Art von Monopolwirtschaft, also nicht, dass Kapitalismus besonders toll wäre, aber ich halte das für ein grundsätzliches Problem von Organisationen, dass es schwer ist, das Know-how so zu halten, dass man hinterher in der Lage ist, auch 20, 30, 50 Jahre in der Zukunft noch richtige Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Also da geht es anscheinend hier auch nicht mehr so sehr darum, machen wir das in diesem Jahr, also machen wir das jetzt gleich, sondern eher sozusagen das im Schirm zu haben und zu sagen, hey Leute, wir müssen es halt irgendwann mal angehen.
Genau, vor 2038 muss echt mal jemand alle Steuerungssysteme angucken, die so eingesetzt werden.
Und wie kommen wir dahin? Oder andersherum gefragt? Es ist ja anscheinend so, das hatte ich ja beim Jahr-2000-Problem auch gesagt, dass es sozusagen schon Programmierer gab, die gesagt haben, hey, vielleicht sollten wir mal und dann war es nicht so. Um bei dem Tech-Priest der Vergleich noch mal zu bleiben, hat die Kaste der Programmierer denn sozusagen, wie sagt man heutzutage, Lifehacks, wie man dahin kommt, dass diese Systeme aktualisiert werden? Kann man seinen Manager-Chef dazu zwingen?
Ja, also wenn ich eine Glaskugel hätte, würde ich sie polieren und würde sehen, dass so gegen 2037 das Innenministerium, dann die Zusammenarbeit mit dem Wirtschaftsministerium, eine Erwähniskampagne startet in den Unternehmen und gleichzeitig im Rahmen der Regulierung für kritische Infrastruktur, Vorschriften gemacht werden, da noch mal rein zu gucken und dann wird es so gegen Mitte 2037 den Managern auffallen, dass es sind ja bloß noch sechs Monate Zeit. Dann werden sie also ganz schnell versuchen, das zu fixen. Also das ist ja kein unbekanntes Problem. Aber es sind jetzt noch 18 Jahre und wir reden darüber und das wissen die natürlich auch. Merkt Euch, wo ihr es zuerst gehört habt. Gibt es auch ein tolles Wort für, habe ich neu gelernt. Das Fachwort für eine endliche Zeit, die man zählt, die dann irgendwann überläuft, ist Epoch oder Epoche. Und 2038 ist dann die Epochalypse. Also die Epochalypse. Also es ist in den Köpfen der Leute schon drin. Ich denke, das wird auch rechtzeitig ankommen. Ein paar Leute werden es verschnarchen und dann werden Dinge passieren. Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass nicht alle von dir beschriebenen Szenarien im Eingang gleichzeitig auftreten, ist dann doch relativ hoch.
Okay, können wir uns erstmal entspannen.
Somit, außer die Leute, die für dieses Thema verantwortlich sind, die sollten das vielleicht auf dem Schirm haben und sich wirklich kümmern.
Also liebe HörerInnen, falls ihr jemand seid, der für solche Systeme verantwortlich ist, und diese Sinnung hört, macht euch an die Arbeit. Liebe anderen HörerInnen, falls ihr nicht so seid, dann gibt es jemanden zu hören in eurem Umfeld, der vielleicht die Verantwortung endlich übernehmen sollte. Ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen eine kleine Musik und dann kommen wir nochmal zurück. Und die Musik kommt von World Beathoven. So. Apropos Zeit, das ist schon auch sehr witzig. Das wird wahrscheinlich das kürzeste Chaosradio aller Zeiten. Weil wir gerade festgestellt haben, wir sind eigentlich sozusagen mit dem eigentlichen Problem schon durch. Also falls Ihr jetzt gerade denkt so, oh Gott, ich muss dringend meine Infrastruktur umbauen, das könnt Ihr jetzt gerne machen. Das Wichtigste haben wir besprochen. Wir machen jetzt noch einen kleinen Ausfall und ein bisschen Drumherum-Geschichte. Das eine ist, als ich am Anfang sagen wollte, dass das Problem ja um 2038, diesem Tag um 4.14 und 7 Sekunden auftritt, hast Du gesagt, nein, das weiß man gar nicht so genau. Das hat mich da verwirrt, weil Du hast ja vorhin erklärt, Unix-Zeit fängt an zu zählen beim 1.1.1970 um 0 Uhr, 0 Uhr, 0.0. Wie kann es dann Abweichungen geben in der Zeit?
Ja, die Antwort ist eigentlich relativ einfach. Die heißt Schaltsekunde. Und zwar dreht sich die Erde ja nicht alle 86.400 Sekunden einmal um sich selbst, sondern nur fast. Und leider auch nicht regelmäßig gleichmäßig. Da gibt es also Menschen, die dafür zuständig sind, zu messen, wie schnell sich die Erde wirklich dreht. Und dann gelingt es sich mal, eine Schaltsekunde einzufügen. Oder auch nicht. Dann werden also die Sekunden nicht von 0 bis 59 gezählt, sondern geht es dann bis 60.
Aber das ist interessant, wie kriegt man das mit? Also ein Schaltjahr, kriegen wir alle den zusätzlichen Tag mit. Den kann man ja sagen. Aber die Schaltsekunde ist noch nie, hat jemand gesagt, jetzt Schaltsekunde.
Das wird rausgegeben, da wird informiert. Das ist nicht viel im Voraus. Es sind immer so sechs Monate im Voraus. Da wird gesagt, okay, am so und so viel um diese und jene Uhrzeit wird eine Schaltsekunde eingeführt.
Wie machen das die Computersysteme?
Ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schwieriges Thema.
Also von dem, was du in der Sendung erklärt hast bis jetzt, würde ich ja denken, du hast ja vorhin gesagt, also die Zeit läuft im Rechner selber und der fragt ab und zu mal nach, wie spät ist es denn? Da würde ich glatt denken, man sagt dem Rechner gar nicht, dass jetzt bald eine Schaltsekunde dran ist, sondern der fragt einfach demnächst nach und stellt fest, okay, ich gehe gerade eine Sekunde zu langsam. Nee, zu schnell.
Es gibt da verschiedene Lösungen für. Das Problem fängt ja damit an, dass die meisten Leute gar nicht wissen, dass der Sekundenwert einer Zeitdarstellung im Prinzip 61 Sekunden umfasst, nicht 60 Sekunden. Dein Programmierer kann schon mal nicht dran gedacht haben, dass sein Wert größer als 59 für die Sekundenanzeige steht. Oh, stimmt. Und das geht den allermeisten Teilen kurz so und dann muss man gucken, wie man damit umgeht. Und jetzt ist die Frage, was hat dein Computer so für Anforderungen? Bei dem, den ich vorhin beschrieben habe, der also tröpfchenweise die Flüssigkeit in den großen Behälter gibt, damit es nicht explodiert, für den ist es ganz schlecht, wenn die Zeit plötzlich sich um eine Sekunde verschiebt. Da kann man das nicht machen. Da gibt es dann das Konzept, dass man sozusagen ganz langsam und schleichend diese eine Sekunde über mehrere Minuten oder vielleicht auch eine Stunde so breit streicht und es langsam dann wieder gerade zieht. Viele Systeme, denen ist einfach egal, die stellen fest, ich gehe eine Sekunde falsch, ich setze das mal neu.
Das kann ich verstehen, aber dieses breite Verstehen verstehe ich nicht. Das heißt, man sagt dem Computer sozusagen, wenn eine Sekunde vorbei ist, warte mal noch eine Millisekunde.
Genau, noch eine Millisekunde und die nächste Sekunde, wieder eine Millisekunde.
Aber das ist ja schon noch ein Spiel mit dem Feuer, weil dann ist ja sozusagen die Minute ist ja dann eine Minute und 60 Millisekunden lang, was nur sozusagen sechstigtausendstel sind, aber trotzdem halt mehr und wenn man, da muss man schon irgendwie vorher rausgefunden haben, wie viel Spielraum diese Eintropfzeit hat.
Genau, genau, genau. Also dann zählt man natürlich nicht bis 1001 oder so, sondern dann macht man den Teiler anders. Also ich hatte ja gesagt, die Zeit wird ja aus einem Quarz abgeleitet, mit so was wie 10 MHz oder so was schwingt, 32 KHz ist verbreitet, weil das kann man dann durch 2 hoch 15 teilen. Und dann dreht man da so ein bisschen dran und dann wird das alles so ein kleines bisschen gestreckt und die Zahlenwerte sehen eigentlich alle völlig in Ordnung aus, außer dass man halt für eine Weile eine Sekunde unsynchron mit dem Rest der Welt läuft, wenn man sich das leisten kann. Also die Frage, was ist sozusagen für deinen Rechner wichtiger, dass du dieselbe Zeit hast wie alle anderen, nicht eine Sekunde Abweichung plötzlich? Oder ob es für dich wichtiger ist, dass die Zeit dir als Prozess kontinuierlich erscheint und ohne Sprünge drin?
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich, ich bin jetzt ein bisschen überrascht, weil das ist in der Tat eigentlich das Gruseligste, was ich heute gehört habe, weil das so ein Punkt ist. Ich kriege das ja als normalen Mensch gar nicht mit, dass eine Schaltsekunde ansteht. Da können wir vielleicht irgendwie eine Showmode, einen Link, wo das angezeigt wird, noch verlinken, weil das finde ich ganz interessant. Ich würde auch gerne mal beobachten, was mein Handy, mein Computer an der Stelle machen. Da musst du ja auch dran denken, wenn du diese Systeme baust, dass dieses Ding irgendwie ansteht.
Das ist hochgradig komplex und die meisten Leute wissen es gar nicht. Auch die Leute, die solche Systeme bauen, wer sich dann wirklich damit beschäftigt, also Zeitzonen sind ja noch schlimmer. Zeitzonen sind ein Grauen, aber auch das wissen viele Leute nicht. Das ist übrigens der Unterschied zwischen, hast du vielleicht schon mal gesehen...
Ne, warte, bevor ich zur Zeitzone gehe, mit diesen Schaltsekunden. Wir haben ja jetzt angefangen, drüber zu reden, weil du gesagt hast, es ist gar nicht so ganz klar, ob diese 4 Uhr 14 und die 7 Sekunden dann wirklich stimmt.
Mein Rechner sagt 4 Uhr 14 und 8 Sekunden, weil das vielleicht schon die aktuelle Schaltsekunde berücksichtigt und im Wikipedia-Eintrag noch nicht.
Es gibt schon die Vereinbarung, dass in der Unix-Zeit die Schaltsekunden auch mitgezählt werden?
Das ist UTC, du kennst ja diese Abkürzung UTC für eine Referenzzeit. Das ist Universal Time Coordinated. Und dieses C steht für diese Koordinierung dieser Schaltsekunden. Es gibt auch eine andere Form, UT1. Dann haben sie einfach angefangen, zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt zu sagen, wir zählen jetzt 86.400 Sekunden für einen Tag. Die Schaltsekunden sind uns egal. Und dieses Zeitdriftet dann so ein bisschen auseinander. Seit den 16, seit es definiert wurde, vielleicht so 12, 13 Sekunden Abweichung ergeben.
Aber die Vereinbarung ist eigentlich Unix-Time macht UTC.
Genau.
Und die Frage ist nur, macht mein Gerät das auch?
Vermutlich schon. Also niemand verwendet UT1, außer Leuten, die wirklich Astronomie über 30 Jahre in Sekundenpräzision tun. Aber ja, tatsächlich ist es so, dass du keine, also mit deinem Computer vermutlich nicht in der Lage bist, für in einem halben Jahr einen Wecker auf die Sekunde genau zu stellen.
Holy shit. Es ist alles noch viel schlimmer als ich dachte. Das ist auch schön, dass man so wie hier in Chaos Radio reingeht und denkt so, ja, also das Problem verstehe ich schon, da gibt es auch eine Lösung für, das Problem ist die Verpaltung der Menschen. Und dann ist es so wie jetzt, nee, ist es gar nicht. Es ist auch, dass Zeit eigentlich gar nicht so richtig fest definiert ist und man es eigentlich gar nicht so genau sagen kann. Das ist schon wirklich sehr seltsam. Okay, gut, aber immerhin auch hier, es gibt eine theoretische Lösung, man muss nur gucken, dass man mit dabei bleibt.
Das ist also 2038-Problem im Prinzip dieselben Lösungen, die man auch für das Jahr-2000-Problem hat. Das heißt im besten Fall, man hat den Source Code noch, man nutzt die Gelegenheit, macht einen 64-Bit-Version draus, baut das neu, konvertiert seine Daten drüber, ist fertig. Im allerschlimmsten Fall läuft da halt ein 30 oder 40 Jahre altes Binary in irgendeiner VM in der Emulation, schimmelt da vor sich hin und irgendjemand muss kommen und mit einem Disassembler das Ding auseinandernehmen und gucken, dass man da was dran drehen kann.
Fangt lieber heute damit an. Aber das sind ja die beiden großen Probleme, also Jahr-2000, Jahr-2038, das sind ja offensichtlich die Probleme, die alle betreffen und jetzt haben wir schon gehört, naja, das Jahr-2008-Problem kann auch schon früher zum Tragen kommen, wenn halt Berechnungen jetzt schon stattfinden, die darüber hinausgehen, aber wie ich jetzt gerade noch gehört habe, gab es schon zwischendurch auch Probleme, die auch damit zu tun haben, wie Zeit verarbeitet wurde, zum Beispiel bei EC-Karten.
Ja, die EC-Karten, die hatten ein sehr lustiges Problem. Ich erwähnte ja vorhin, dass in einem Byte zwei Ziffern gespeichert wurden. Das ist die sogenannte BCD-Darstellung, Binary Coded Digits. Mit 8 Bit, ein Byte, kannst Du ja eigentlich von 0 bis 256 zählen. Wenn Du jetzt aber sowas wie eine 23 hast, dann musst Du also erstmal anfangen, 23, muss man irgendwie nur 0, 1, 0, 0 und dann muss man durch die Gegend schieben, gucken, was ist jetzt mal eine 10er Stelle, was mal eine 1er Stelle. Du musst eigentlich die Zahl durch 10 dividieren, damit Du die 10er Stelle rauskriegst, sonst hast Du die 1er Stelle noch übrig. Und was man da machen kann, ist die sogenannte BCD-Darstellung. Nimmt man nämlich jeweils 4 Bit für eine Stelle. 4 Bit für die 1er und 4 Bit für die 10er Stelle. Mit 4 Bit kann man eigentlich von 0 bis 15 zählen. Und die Werte ignoriert man aber. Wenn da 0,0,1,0,0,0,1,0 steht, ist es 22. Weil 0,0,1,0 ist 2 und nochmal 0,0,1,0 ist auch 2. Wo es eigentlich was anderes wäre.
Aber das wirft man dann weg.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast das Jahr 2000, du speicherst nur die letzten beiden Ziffern, in BCD-Darstellung hast du 0, 0. Jetzt nimmst du diesen Byte-Wert und rechnest den plus 1. Dann bist du bei 0, 1. Rechnest du plus 1, bist du bei 0, 2. Bist du bei 0, 9, rechnest du jetzt plus 1, musst du an der Stelle aufpassen, dass du auch eine BCD-Rechnung machst. Das heißt, einen Übertrag in die nächste Stelle. Dass du dann auf den 10 kommst, weil wenn du das nicht tust, landest du nämlich bei 0, a. Und 0, a ist keine Dezimalzahl. Und das ist 2010 bei den C-Karten passiert, und dann haben da welche aufgehört zu funktionieren.
Was? Also war das ein Problem der konkreten Karte, die ich in der Hand habe, oder ein Problem bestimmter Anbieter, die das für ihre Karten gemacht haben?
Das war meines Erachtens ein Problem bestimmter Technologie-Bausteine, die es nicht hingekriegt haben. Oder ein anderes sehr beliebtes Beispiel ist...
Wir gräsen heute schon sozusagen die Albträume von Zivilisationsmenschen ab. Flugzeug stürzt ab, Bankautomat frisst die Karte. Also verschiedene Extremstufen, aber das sind so Zivilisationsängste, die begründet sind, wie ich heute lerne. Warte, warte, warte. Das nächste ist, ich fahre los, habe natürlich keine Papierkarte mehr dabei und mein Navi funktioniert nicht mehr.
Das wird natürlich auch passieren. Also auch das hatten wir. Im April letzten Jahres. Was? Das Global Positioning System. Wahrscheinlich hast du wieder Glück gehabt und hast einen Upgrade gekriegt. Und nichts wirklich Schlimmes ist passiert. Aber das Original GPS-System hat ein Zeitformat, wo die Anzahl der Monate in 10 Bit gespeichert wurde. Also da gab es auch einen Starttermin. Und dann haben sie jeweils eins hochgezählt pro Woche. Immer mal diese Darstellung. Warum auch mal sie auf die Idee gekommen sind. Auf jeden Fall haben sie dafür 10 Bit verwendet. Und dieser 10-Bit-Zähler ist halt übergelaufen. Und zwar im April 2019. Und nun braucht man bei GPS die Zeit, um die Position ausrechnen zu können. Aus den Messwerten der Satelliten. Weil die Position der Satelliten, plus die Zeit, die Satelliten bewegen sich, die GPS-Satelliten. Das heißt, du musst die aktuelle Zeit kennen, um aus der Konstellation deine Position auf der Erde ausrechnen zu können. Und wenn das halt schief geht, weil das Zeitformat nicht stattfindet, dann bist du halt irgendwo.
Ich muss kurz fragen, weil ich verstehe es nicht ganz genau. Also eine GPS-Software weiß quasi, wo die Satelliten zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt stehen sollten. Und macht dann sozusagen, wenn es das Signal kriegt, dann weiß es sozusagen, ok, ich bin hier, dafür muss es aber wissen, wie spät es ist.
Genau das. Was gemessen wird, ist im Prinzip die Entfernung zum Satelliten, die Laufzeit zum Satelliten. Daraus, welche Satelliten du mit welcher Laufzeit siehst, kannst du dann mit Hilfe der aktuellen Zeit ausrechnen, wo du bist.
Mit Hilfe der aktuellen Zeit, ok.
Und wenn du die nicht hast, wenn die nicht stimmt, dann bist du halt nicht an der richtigen Stelle.
Wie hat sich das geäußert damals?
Sie haben rechtzeitig alle Geräte aus dem Verkehr gezogen, weil es war wirklich ein sehr, sehr alter Standard. Das war auch so was, das wussten die und dann haben sie auch vor 20 Jahren angefangen, das zu reparieren. Und es gab trotzdem Warnungen für Flugzeuge und Schiffe, doch bitte mal nachzugucken, ob man vielleicht einen alten GPS-Receiver an Bord hat.
Noch was? Oder haben wir es jetzt? Ich glaube langsam haben wir es. Ok, aber noch eine letzte Frage von mir. Dieses Ding, das, also wir haben heute über Zeit geredet. Und das Problem ist ja eigentlich, in einem Computer wird Speicherplatz reserviert, um etwas zu repräsentieren. Weil es hier um Zeit ging, ist es auch besonders kritisch. Aber dieses Problem, frage ich mich gerade, tritt das noch an anderer Stelle auf? Also der Computer hat für irgendwas begrenzt Speicherplatz. Und ich rede jetzt nicht davon, dass das Spiel abstürzt, weil die Grafikkarte zu schwach ist, sondern sozusagen andere Probleme dieser Schwere?
Das ist tatsächlich eine sehr verbreitete Quelle von Sicherheitsproblemen in Computern. Sagen wir mal, du bist ein Programm auf einem Computer. Du nimmst Daten aus dem Netzwerk entgegen. Und du reservierst jetzt einen Speicherbereich, wo die Daten aus dem Netz reingeschrieben werden, die da so ankommen. Jetzt kommt da einer und sagt irgendwie, ich habe hier jetzt 4 GB Daten für dich. Und du bist ein 32-Bit-System und 32 Bit kann 4 GB adressieren. Das sind wir über den 4 Milliarden. Und du denkst dir, das ist toll, da brauche ich irgendwie 4 GB plus nochmal 20. Das sind dann zusammen 18. Als das immer übergelaufen ist. Dann reservierst du also einen 18-Bit-großen Bereich im Speicher. Dann nimmst du 4 GB aus dem Netz entgegen aus dem Internet und schreibst ihn in deinen Speicher rein. Und zwar schön über alle Datenstrukturen dahinter liegen drüber. Das kann der geneigte Hacker natürlich dazu ausnutzen, da das hinzuschreiben, was er haben möchte. Nämlich zum Beispiel seine Software, die dann den Trojaner runterlädt und auf deinem Rechner installiert und alle deine Dateien verschlüsselt.
Das ist auch interessant, weil wir noch im Nebenbei spazieren, die eine grundlegende Funktionalität für Betriebssysteme oder Systeme kaputt machen, erklärt haben. Was ich eher meinte, ist, dass Ressourcen alle werden. Zum Beispiel bei IP-Adressen ist das ja auch so. Wir haben häufiger im Chaosradio über IP-Adressen geredet. Diese Zahlen, die aus vier Triplets bestehen, also 191, 256, 191, 1 oder so, ist vielleicht die von eurem Bruder zu Hause. Und die waren ja auch alle, weil es weltweit mittlerweile so viele Geräte gibt, dass es nicht mal ausreicht, die noch irgendwie anders aufzuteilen. Aber gibt es so eine Ressourcenprobleme noch, die anstehen, die man absehen kann? Weil Dinge sozusagen ausgezählt sind? Oder sind wir damit jetzt erstmal durch? Bestimmt, aber wir wissen noch nicht davon.
So groß wie das Jahr-2038-Problem oder dass die IP-Adressen uns ausgehen, fallen mir gerade nicht ein. Im Kleinen gibt es sowas natürlich ständig.
Na gut, Andreas Bogk, dann vielen Dank.
Es war mir ein Vergnügen.
Mir auch und wir sind jetzt sozusagen alle. Unsere Zeit ist abgelaufen.
Wir treffen uns dann in 18 Jahren hier und sagen told you so.
Aber ich hoffe, im guten Weg. Damals, 2020, haben wir die Sendung gemacht, die dazu gehört hat, dass die ganze Welt ordentlich geguckt hat und das Jahr 2038-Problem geklärt hat. Und dann sage ich jetzt noch das, was ich immer Ende von meinem Chaosradio immer sage. Und das ist ja auch wichtig, also besonders wichtig im Bezug auf den Programmiercode, der nicht verloren gehen soll. Lasst Euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön Eure Backups.